um well congratulations on your
engagement
um and the reason why i bring it up as
well is i asked him i was like well how
did you
propose and i didn't know if you might
but do you mind telling everybody how it
was beautiful oh
no we i had no idea obviously i just was
like in fact we i was trying to get out
of going
back to oklahoma because it was getting
too complicated with covid and yeah the
family and
and um i'm like i think we just canceled
the trip you know it was like one of
those like yeah and
then we got it all together and we ended
up going and so his sister
and her family they were there my kids
were there
and um my brother and his family we're
all there we always are all there
and um we were gonna go see we're
building a house there so we were gonna
go
from the one part of the land to the
other part of the land to go see the
house
and meanwhile i guess blake had had this
ring like ready to go for like a couple
weeks
and he had nobody knew like nobody knew
my dad
knew because on my birthday he had
showed my dad and said he was going to
do it or whatever
oh my god he's so old-fashioned he's
trying to talk to your dad first well i
had my birthday party and it wasn't a
party it was a birthday covered
moment in my house when i turned
whatever it was i turned
and then anyway so we got there and
everybody was like
no we got to get back we're cooking like
a hobo stew on the
fire and we can't let it burn and my son
was like no i got to go to the bathroom
i don't want to go
and like it was like all these like
things happening and and i walked in
and my son was like sitting right by
this like fireplace
and blake basically like was getting
down on his knees to do a fire and he
goes hey can you look in that cabinet
over there and get me
get me a fire starter so i opened the
cabinet and there was like a ring in a
box and i was like
ah like what are you serious and then
so everybody like came running around
because i guess they heard us screaming
or whatever and crying and
um so there was no video it was just
like my sister-in-law
was just like shooting pictures and
that's that photo that we put out so
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever